where's McGarrett when you really need
them so after that false incoming
missile alert in Hawaii launch
notifications will now require
verification by two people you think
that would have been in place already
and maybe a warning that prompts you to
double check a message before it goes
out I mean when I want to delete an
email I'm asked are you sure you want to
delete an email and that's for an email
not a state alert telling people they're
about to die and here's a thought
maybe don't have the menu item for
incoming missile so close to one that
says just testing that's like having the
kids trampoline next to a wood chipper
this screw-up cannot be overstated
imagine if it were you your family being
told you were all gonna die and for 40
minutes that's your reality then someone
comes along and says oops now my wife
was there in Hawaii she saw mothers
sobbing uncontrollably realizing that
they would never see their kids again
she watched families saying goodbye and
yet the press is already back to the
swear word what a contrast between real
terror and phony posturing the same
people who report this missile accident
with such restraint just days ago were
melting over [ __ ] when the press
conference in Hawaii hit we took it live
CNN Rani repeats interview with Michael
Wolfe a repeat maybe if that false
missile warning had s hole in it
CNN would have gone wall-to-wall it's
disgusting that event that led mothers
to place children in storm drains is of
less interest to the press that accrued
phrase uttered in a meeting but I guess
if you can't blame the usual villain
then why bother oh wait you can our
leaders have failed a Donald Trump is
taking too long he's not taking this
threat seriously and there's no time to
waste
we've got to get rid of this nuclear
threat from North Korea we've got to
achieve peace not play politics play
politics what did she just do her
state's warning system screwed up and
now Trump has to make his geopolitical
calculations based on that
no how about setting up a system that
doesn't terrify people for 38 minutes
and then you can take part in the
conversation until then fix your own
backyard
this infuriates me if this had happened
Dana in New York City the media would
care the media would carry instead
they've already moved on about the most
ridiculous things certainly anything
that happens in New York gets over
covered you know that sometimes it's
warranted you would think that people
would like an opportunity to go to
Hawaii to get our story thankfully it
was a false alarm and I think it really
did expose a lot of the holes in the
system
the system that's good and I also think
that it taught it showed holes in our
own family planning yeah right after
9/11 there was a big push it was it
called ready.gov it was part of the
department of homeland security and
there was a big advertising push to to
talk to families about having a plan
that if something happens this is where
we are going to meet up this is how
we're gonna get together whether you
need to have cash where you have like
some sort of protection enough food
enough water things like that and we've
really gotten away from that and this
was a big wake-up call for people
including me well you know Jesse this is
a wake up call
we assigned the worker they didn't fire
him but they got it they got to do
something with the entire Emergency
Management System of Hawaii they must if
they have to fire more than one person
yeah for me this is about a big
government screw-up they screwed up so
instead of saying false alarm they
didn't have anything ready to go in the
script
they took 38 minutes to come up with
this are you ready
there is no missile threat or danger to
Hawaii
repeat false alarm it took 40 minutes
for them to cook up that tweet yeah I
cannot believe that and they don't fire
anybody they reassigned them what does
it take basically cause mass hysteria
and a huge tape and the guy gets
reassigned so the party that wants
bigger government is okay with this they
screw up so big in the state of Hawaii
don't take any responsibility for it
compound the screw up and then the
Democrats want to give
government more power over people's
lives they want more power over health
care more power over your life
we're power over your business this is
the reason why we don't have big bloated
government this is the exact reason it's
amazing you know about that 40 minutes
Kimberly they claimed that they were
waiting for an approval for the
retraction
but according to john roberts fema fema
didn't they didn't need authorization
they knew five minutes this thing was
was not real they many people's lives
hell
yeah well obviously they have to really
revamp and retool the system and don't
think that the rest of the states right
now and like scramble calm mode to say
what can we do to make sure that we
don't end up looking like Hawaii and
have a major problem because this is
like really unacceptable and I don't
like when somebody gets sort of reward
like oh we'll just reassign you usually
it's to a better job position or more
money or something like ridiculous but
this is a serious issue of national
security and people were in complete and
utter chaos and panic like you said your
wife was it and saw it
so let me I wasn't there you know you
know I'm the guy in the mirror I'm the
guy in the disaster movie that people
slap wake up they would be slapping me
she would have seen the worst part of me
I'm sure she's seen it all that's true
one I felt that Tulsi Gabbard made that
incredibly that leap to North Korea a
very political leap and had nothing to
do with North Korea it had to do with
daring competence that was but that that
you got to focus on the incompetence you
don't immediately jump and blame Trump
over his relationship with North Korea
that is absurd I don't think it's absurd
well explain well that's where the
threat comes from the threat was there
incompetence
no no the threat is that North Korea is
4,500 miles stated in and do this Hawaii
and so everybody wants to deal with the
source of the threat you can talk about
you know if this was badly managed I
agree with Jesse 100% if you knew within
five minutes that it was a
false alarm why did it take you 30 to 40
minutes to tell the public you just felt
better Yeah right
trust fault no no but I mean you just
like to anything to defend Trump but I'm
just no it's anything to do that's the
point oh this is so cute
no it's not let me just nothing I would
love to let me tell you something what
you see here is the Trump didn't take it
seriously so you should be screaming at
Trump because Trump never ever responded
to it and in fact one of the complaints
from the people that you loathe Jamie
Lee Curtis you know Montel Williams of
that right yet today all those people
are saying crickets
nothing from the President of the United
States you wanted to respond emotionally
I thought that I think he should respond
as president of the United States and
one of the kids I think we have a sound
on tape of Donald Trump responding
concern is don't blame me wasn't me this
that's his concern as opposed to
expressing even some of your outrage
over either gonna say a priority and
proportion is so off it's disgusting
Dana mm-hmm well I wasn't gonna comment
on that I'm just gonna say that the
question about the concern about it
being a hack yeah I think it's a very
real one right cyber terror is something
that can come in lots of different forms
we probably haven't couldn't even
conceive of all the forms that could
come in but our responsibility either
state or local government or even the
federal government is to try to be more
creative than whatever a criminal or a
hacker might do because that if you have
panic like that that leads to an
accident whether it just be because
people crash into each other on the
highway trying to get out or something
much worse including a retaliation then
you know you can lose a lot of lives for
nothing yeah let me Juan brought up some
of the single-digit I queued celebrities
like Jamie Lee Curtis and the odious Jim
Carrey who should just go away go far
away let me quote Jim Carrey of course
what does he do he blames Trump says it
was a false alarm but
real psychic warning because he's really
deep like that he understands psychic
warnings we allow this one man Kimura
and his corrupt Republican Congress to
continue a leading in the word world we
are headed for suffering beyond all
imagination so clearly Kimberly he's
mentally ill he here you have a system
that failed its people any-any he goes
after Trump this guy has got serious
problem how are you disturbed that there
is no causal or logical connection
strange man syndrome yes I see we have a
Flintstone vitamin for you then Greg so
yeah this is what's happening that you
at one point are you going to be like
not surprised and non-plus by this
you're gonna say this is what they do
and if there's any way to try to connect
it that's why you went out of his way
POTUS to say I'm glad they took
responsibility for it at the state level
nevertheless we're gonna work
cooperatively with them a national level
to make sure that these types of things
don't happen okay so he tried to button
it up nevertheless they're saying this
is president Trump's fault and they want
to characterize it and miss characterize
it as the most reckless presidency and
dangerous presidency in the history of
the world right I mean that's the whole
approach to say this is the same guy who
was insulting Kim jong-un who we all
think is on edge anyway and that cuz he
calls him rocky man then he says oh no
you know what my button is bigger than
Europe but talk about infantile talk
about making the United States high able
is he able to understand his power you
wouldn't let this destroy oh no no we're
talking about a far more serious threat
than some government guy making a
mistake we're talking about cause it's
the it's the largest example of shouting
fire in a theater and you don't think
it's a big deal that's weird what I'm
saying is the bigger deal is if North
Korea actually fires a nuclear weapon in
Hawaii and if you don't understand that
you're
but we're not talking about that you
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to create a different context no
we're focused on that isn't Trump
himself was very careful to say it was
the Stasi he's talking about the state
yes and you what you nervous Christian
Nielsen yesterday she writers was an
unfortunate mistake that's all it was
well I feel much more safe under
commander in chief Trump than I would
under commander in chief Obama but I
want to ask you I thought these isn't it
clear President Obama did anything so on
the celebrity thing it's so fight so
they blame Trump for someone pushing a
button in Hawaii
Chelsea Handler blamed Trump for the
wildfires in California or Jennifer
Lawrence blamed Trump for the hurricane
because God was mad at his election and
Lena Dunham
blamed Trump for her weight loss yes so
anything bad that happens it's Trump's
fault but if it does anything good you
should get ready to him for the weight
loss by the way by the way yogurt for
brains Jamie Lee Curtis said the Hawaii
missile scare is on You mr. Trump you
the real fear that mothers and fathers
and children felt is on you she this
does no help for the people that were
panicking right that were panicky at
that time is putting it on Trump what
he'll what this is this is self-survival
on decock preening look at me look at me
look at me shut up and eat your yogurt
that looked like a cry to hell yeah that
was when you're using caps and you're
like 50 she has other issues with the
filming of True Lies that she should be
focusing on instead of this Google that
people oh here we go hey did you hear
about the true-life scandal hit the t's
all right everybody knows what I'm
talking about